detenidos y golpeados en su camino a
estados unidos muchos migrantes
desahogan su desesperación estoy
buscando la bala de edad cualquier
batería
[Música]
tras los controles la policía mexicana
detuvo 80 de las 300 personas que
seguían la caravana migrantes que han
recorrido unos 100 kilómetros desde el
sábado cuando salieron de tapachula a
una ciudad del sur de méxico en ese
momento eran 700 pero tras varios
enfrentamientos con la guardia nacional
mexicana más de la mitad de ellos
abandonaron su viaje esta es la tercera
caravana que intenta llegar al norte de
mexico
de las fuerzas la persona no puede
imagínate la persona durmiendo para acá
a última hora del miércoles durante una
redada los agentes irrumpieron en varias
casas para detener a los migrantes que
intentaban esconderse y se produjeron
nuevamente violentos enfrentamientos
varias agencias de naciones unidas como
acnur y la organización internacional
para las migraciones que siguieron a las
autoridades mexicanas respetar los
derechos humanos de los migrantes
y por no me quiero entregar porque mi
esposo y mis dos hijos se los llevaron
no quiero seguir solas
las caravanas de migrantes aumentaron
desde que el presidente estadounidense
joe biden asumió la presidencia el
pasado mes de mayo el mandatario anunció
que eeuu acogería en 2021 a cuatro veces
más migrantes de los que había previsto
su predecesor donald trump pero reiteró
posteriormente que las fronteras no
estaban abiertas para hacer frente a las
oleadas migratorias méxico ha desplegado
cerca de 30.000 agentes armados a lo
largo de sus fronteras